azira village may seem calm but it's at
the center of a heated dispute between
sudan and ethiopia
for more than a century both countries
have fought for its surrounding border
area alpha saga a rich and fertile
region of about 250 square kilometers al
jazeera has gained rare access to the
village where the latest rise in
violence has emerged
sudan says seven of its soldiers and one
civilian were recently kidnapped by
ethiopian forces
their bodies left mutilated
one of the villagers was a family member
it's not uncommon for our ethiopian
neighbors to kidnap or kill us for
ransom they demand huge sums of money we
are forced to either pay or be killed
the ethiopian government denies the
accusations it says a local rebel group
is responsible and has promised to
investigate the attack
sudan says there's no time to waste and
is sending military reinforcements to
the area
our armed forces must respond to this
assault one of our duties is to protect
our citizens homeland and property it is
our duty to safeguard the international
border lines of sudan
the alpha saga region lies within
sudan's international boundaries but
ethiopians have long settled in the area
and cultivated its
land behind these sudanese mountains
ethiopian forces are reportedly on high
alert
especially after the sudanese army
recaptured vast areas of farming land
which were controlled by ethiopia for
decades
now the threat of violence has made it
difficult to farm the nearby lands
we are gripped with fear we are
suffering the cost of living is soaring
and women are forced to take other
low-paying jobs we no longer enjoy the
dignified life we had in the past
the tension isn't new but it is
escalating partly fueled by border
disputes and also the construction of
ethiopia's hydroelectric dam on the blue
nile which sudan fears will compromise
its water supply
and now the killing of soldiers has
renewed their mutual mistrust
katie lopez